the Joe Rogan experience why did you
write the book well what was what was
your goal like when you when you sat
down you decided you're gonna write this
book how to fight an anti-semitism what
what were you thinking well first of all
I wrote I was supposed to write another
book that I'm still on the hook for I
went and begged my publisher to do this
because after Pittsburgh I just kind of
couldn't stop seeing it everywhere I
looked and honestly like yeah I think a
Pittsburgh hadn't happened I wouldn't
have written this first but I just
became so passionate about it and so
passionate about here's I think maybe
the shortest answer for this when we
talk about anti-semitism even you and I
like we think about Jews like the Jews
on the streets of Brooklyn or in
Pittsburgh or in that synagogue in
California as being the victims of it
but the act and they are but the real
bigger victim of it is the surrounding
society like when anti-semitism shows
itself in a culture it means that that
culture is extremely broken or in some
stage of death and the reason that I
think it's so important and the reason I
ultimately wrote the book is I want
people to understand that the fact that
anti-semitism is rising in America says
nothing about Jews it says everything
about America and where we are right now
like we don't want to be come a place
where anti-semitism is normalized
because guess what societies were
anti-semitism become normalized or
societies that no longer exist on the
face of the earth I like how you
described in your book as a symptom like
that we all have certain bacteria or we
all have certain viruses but our immune
system keeps them at bay when those
viruses show themselves it's a it's a
sign that the immune system is weak that
the body itself is weak
yes that's exactly right couldn't said
it better that's all I said yeah I think
that's true and the question right is
how do we rebuild back our immune system
and one of the reasons that I'm alarmed
by and I completely understand the
populist moment but I'm also scare
of it because populism often does not
end well for Jews or for the political
center and I think one of one of the
reasons that we need to like how do we
rebuild our immune system like those are
the sort of things that I suggest in the
last chapter of the book and I think I
just I just hope we can do them because
I'm really really alarmed that we're
living in an America in 2020 where
people I know you know who wear a Jewish
star like put it inside their shirt when
they walk down the street that's crazy
mmm like that's crazy to me imagine if
that was a crucifix exactly in fear yeah
I mean to say nothing by the way of like
Jews in France that have you know
they've been hiding themselves for a
very very long time that's normal
they're you know a lot of Jews I know
are taking shooting lessons I just had a
guy reach out to me that was like I read
your book I've read your speeches I
think you're great but none of them are
gonna help you if someone attacks you on
the street let me teach you like Krav
Maga self-defense something to do that
are you really oh yeah of course I am
agog legit yeah I'm definitely doing it
basically take the best aspects of all
martial arts and combine them together
striking grappling
self-defense techniques I'm gonna do it
you get a gun I can't I live in New York
you can get a gun in New York no I got
it
really yeah it's not that hard I have to
say I hate like the few times that I've
gone shooting I hate it yeah I really do
dresses me out okay I'll go with you I
might enjoy it more okay I'll do it okay
are you serious yeah I'll take you for
sure next time you're in town I'll take
you to tear and tactical hey the other
light up some target
[Applause]